[Musik]
nein
hallo zusammen wir machen heute die
beiden torte die eight orte ich weiß es
ist das porträt sich nicht aussprechen
kann das ist die torte quasi die man für
das ramadanfest zubereitet also ich
mache mal jedes jahr eine ich mache sie
mal viel viel früher damit ihr sie auch
nach machen könnt aber das ist einfach
schon ein ritual hier auf meinem kanal
während man ramadan reihe und ich habe
vorab auf instagram gefragt was wir
haben möchtet beziehungsweise was ich
dieses jahr machen soll ich kann mich ja
mal so die vom letzten jahr ein blenden
wir hatten ja irgendwie immer so dieses
dieses mondsichel symbolen und ich finde
das gehört auch immer dazu das würde ich
heute auch gerne machen und viel
abgeschrieben etwas fruchtiges jemand
schrieb nichts schweres bitte etwas was
zwei linke hände nachmachen können ich
möchte gerne einfache und fruchtige
dinge und deswegen habe ich mir genau
dass wir heute überlegt also es wird
einfach ist ihr könnt es nach meiner
anleitung wirklich schritt für schritt
einfach nachmachen da braucht sich keine
sorgen machen ich werde sehr kleinen
schritt ich erklären und ich habe euch
wie immer alle ganz genauen
mengenangaben hier unten in die infobox
ich starte jetzt auch direkt mit
fluffigen bizkit bilden das ist die
basis unserer torte und der biss gibt
boden schmeckt halt einfach auch so
schon lecker und daher musste der jetzt
mit in die torte ich muss jetzt erst mal
eier trennen und es darf wirklich kein
bisschen eigelb ins eiweiß weil sonst
lässt es sich nicht aufschlagen dieses
fett vom eigelb hindert das eiweiß daran
richtig schön steif zu werden und daher
könnt ihr das immer schön separate erst
mal so eine kleine schüssel aufschlagen
dann das eigelb hin und her schieben
damit das komplette eiweiß auch
verwertet so und dann kommt das in eine
separate schüssel und so gebe ich das
jetzt immer könnt ihr euch sicher sein
dass wirklich nichts vom allgemein kommt
so könnt ihr das immer nacheinander jene
große schüssel geben wenn ihr keine
küchenmaschine habe dann nehmt sie
einfach ein handrührgerät
[Musik]
so zum weiß gehen wir jetzt noch eine
gute diese salz
dann kommt der schnee diesen aufsatz
vorne dran und das wird dann erst mal
richtig schön dick geschlagen geht dann
ruhig hoch mit der geschwindigkeit ich
werde auch enden bei der maximalen
geschwindigkeit und sobald ihr merkt
dass es schön dick ist gibt die hälfte
des zuckers mit dazu und schlagt es
nochmals zu einer richtig dicken weißen
baiser masse
[Musik]
so die mir sehen was ist fertig so steif
sollte sie sein und jetzt kann beruhigt
dran kaufen es gibt ja den mythos dass
man sagt wenn man dran klopft dann
verschwinden die luft blasen aber da
passiert gar nichts und das war wenn ich
jetzt weiter denn ich bin jetzt einfach
zu faul zum spülen aber es ist ja auch
gar nicht an der stelle denn das ist
sowieso vereint und eigelb ist da so ein
bisschen pflegeleichter darf wo ich
jetzt die eiweiß must run und das gebe
ich jetzt hier einfach komplett in die
schüssel mit dem restlichen zucker da
gebe ich dann gleich auch schon vanille
extrakt abzukippen super geschmack und
dann wird das auch 34 minuten lang
richtig schön dick cremig geschlagen
wenn ein handrührgerät verwendet dann
braucht ihr noch ein bisschen länger
[Musik]
so sieht jetzt die eigelb zucker massa
ich will das mal so fasziniert dass sie
dir schon fast aus sind ein ständiger
teig dabei ist es nur ein gap und zucker
und vanille extrakt so und da gebe ich
jetzt diese masse ich hab sie
unterrichtet sie mich rein also die muss
jetzt mit ganz viel liebe unter gehoben
werden und unterheben bedeutet immer ihr
nehmt euch einen teig schaber die arbeit
kann auch keine maschine ersetzen und
dann mach dir wirklich so kreisende
bewegungen von außen nach innen immer
wieder von außen nach innen und wenn ihr
merkt dass sich das verbunden hat dann
nehmt ihr euch schon mal das nächste
bisschen also so dass ihr das sind vier
schritten ungefähr überholt oder fünf
das ist auch okay
[Musik]
icbc massa vollständig untergehoben
bitte nur solange unternehmen wie
notwendig also nicht zu viel sondern
wirklich nur so lange bis es sich
verbunden hat und das gleiche gilt auch
für die trockenen zutaten
da haben wir mehr speisestärke und
backpulver falls sich fragt wofür die
speisestärke die lok hat das einfach
noch einmal auf und dann wird das auch
also ich gebe zwar alles jetzt gerade in
der hand sieht aber eigentlich mache ich
so dass es so ein bisschen drücke dann
geht es wieder zur seite dann hab ich
unter gleiche bewegung die gerade und
dann mache ich es wieder so dass ich ein
bisschen was dazu gebe von den trockenen
zutaten das ganze auch in 345 einzelnen
schritten und dann ist der teig fast
fertig ich würde ihn aber gern noch
kippen weil das soll eine fruchtige
torte werden und deshalb bröselig gleich
einfach noch tiefgekühlte himbeeren
reine können natürlich auch frische
nehmen aber ich habe beides da und hab
gedacht die tiefkühl werden müssen jetzt
auch mal weg
[Musik]
so die himbeeren nur ganz kurz
unterheben und dann können wir auch
schon mal die zwei torten ringe
vorbereiten die haben bei mir einen
durchmesser von 18 zentimetern und die
werden mit backpapier eingeschlagen das
geht ganz einfach das packpapier einfach
immer wieder einschlagen bis ihr einmal
in der runde angekommen seid und dann
habt ihr quasi einen boden es ist
auslaufsicher und so könnt ihr mit zwei
tortenring gleichzeitig backen ist ja
auch mein gelocktes backblech das ist
die ideale unterlage dafür und er geht
das geht natürlich auch mit dem normalen
backblech wenn ihr das jetzt gerade
nicht da habt dann habt ihr allerdings
diese werbung daher umso besser wenn ihr
das richtig ordentlich einschlag bei der
werbung kann es euch passieren diese
werbung ist ganz normal in so standard
backbleche kann passieren dass es
einfach unten drunter rausrutscht und
ihr dann einen schiefen teig haft oder
der eine teil ist niedriger als der
andere und das kann man eben vermeiden
und jetzt wird der teig gleichmäßig
aufgeteilt und dann gebacken ich hab den
ofen auch schon vorgeheizt 180 grad ober
und unterhitze und ich muss gleich noch
auf einer unterlage aber ich glaube es
war etwas mehr als 30 minuten und hier
müsst ihr einfach darauf achten dass wir
das gleichmäßig einfüllt ich habe mir
dafür die in scala dann kann ich genau
gucken es sei denn ihr habt ein gutes
augenmass dann braucht ihr sohn skyler
nicht aber ich habe kein gutes augenmaß
und da gucke ich einfach dass das
einigermaßen gleich hoch ist
[Musik]
ich bekomme besuch von einem special
guest also nichts gebacken haben mehr
oder mehr
der ist fast 6 cm
das wird die exporte
kannst du mal aussprechen so richtig
und wichtig kambodscha ist verlangte
weiter ich sag immer bei hafentor
das ist auf jeden fall die schwierigste
arabische buchstabe im ganzen arabischen
alphabet das ist was kaputt das ist oder
kennt sich sehr gut aus also mascarpone
kommt jetzt in die rührschüssel wir
machen jetzt gerade die creme schon mal
fertig sind mir gedacht haben war ich
mache so ein klassiker so ist es ja auch
so bald also ist der sommer aber es ist
so und lingen bald kommt der sommer
ich muss klassisch also richtig schön
größte frische creme ist nicht schlimm
und dann kommt hier zur mascarpone kommt
jetzt noch kalte schlagsahne
[Musik]
nein das hatte ich schon letztes jahr
nicht noch mal so und dann gehen wir für
zucker dazu für die süße ja klar ich
feiere das ist einfach kommst du mir
hilft
beides funktioniert hier 13
dann in extra kommt rein also es wird
halt wirklich schön übernimmt cremen so
nicht zu wenig obwohl das ist selbst
noch stärker konzentriert eigentlich
braucht die weniger aber ich ja im boden
habe schon ordentlich aber es kann ja
nicht genug für die positiven so richtig
pünktchen hat also genau und jetzt
schlagen wir das erst langsam weil sonst
schaut euch die sahne überall so eröffne
langsam verrühren dann immer schneller
genau immer schneller werden und wären
besten irgendwann einfach sagen fest ein
riesen und dann schauen dass es einfach
so schön festwirt und steif wird soll
ich mal so dass diese so was ja schon
dass sein zustand ist recht
viel spaß
[Musik]
die creme ist jetzt im kühlschrank weil
wir müssen noch warten dass die böden
etwas auskühlen bevor ich die durch
schneide aber ich kümmere mich in der
zwischenzeit schon mal um mein obst das
habe ich schon gewaschen und getrocknet
und das jetzt einfach in kleine feine
stückchen geschnitten und außerdem habe
ich mir überlegt weil ich habe mal
gelesen was hier geschrieben haben viele
mich geschrieben ist so etwas einfaches
seine aufwendigere projekt habe ich in
den letzten jahren also relativ könnt
ihr euch gerne man schon verlinke ich
euch in die infobox und diesmal habe ich
mir gedacht wir basteln uns einen cache
popa und da habe ich ja im shop diese
beidseitige
skateboards die sind ja super stabile
könnte auch mehrmals verwenden aber
heute werde ich durch schneiden dann
nehme ich die goldene seite nach vorne
hier haben wir schwarz könnte auch
machen aber ich bin gott einfach
passender und da werde ich mir gleich
einfach den diese mondsichel
ausschneiden und dann mit kate ob stehen
hinten befestigen und dann habt ihr
euren körper schon fertig
[Musik]
so das ist jetzt unser selfmade kate
aber ich finde ihn wunderschön und mir
gefällt die goldene seite sehr sehr gut
und diese zwei cake pops spiele habe ich
einfach nur noch mit tesa wand befestigt
das kommt jetzt kurz an die seite und
wir kümmern uns um die abgekühlten böden
ich habe sie übrigens grad kurz abgelegt
ins gefrierfach getan dann bestanden ihr
das einfach so ein bisschen und da nehme
ich jetzt den backform löser und werde
jetzt einfach ganz vorsichtig diese
feinen böden von tortenring entfernen
danach einfach das backpapier
untendrunter abziehen und dann schneide
ich dass entweder einmal durch dann habt
ihr dickere böden das sind die finanzen
böden nicht so cool weil man hat dann
viel teig aber bei dem werden weil die
halt so locker und weiß dann finde ich
das gar nicht schlimm und die haben ja
auch noch hinten drin oder das
entscheide ich mich ganz spontan
vielleicht teile ich dir auch zweimal
durch dann habe ich hier drei bilden und
die drei bilden und dann habe ich
einfach mehr schichten heute bin ich
ganz spontan ich würde übrigens auch
noch weil ich gesehen habe wie
abgeschrieben macht was mit deiner
pistazien creme und ich habe ja schon
zwei rezepte mit pistazien käme ich habe
den distanzen milch kuchen und pistazien
paris brest und da habe ich jetzt
gedacht mache ich einfach so dass ich
die pistazien kriegt einfach nochmal auf
die böden streiche da könnt ihr dann
auch zum beispiel wenn es noch
fruchtiger möchtet marmelade oder chia
lade drauf streichen das ist euch
überlassen
[Musik]
also die pistazien habe ich jetzt noch
mal für zehn sekunden bei 600 watt in
die mikrowelle erwärmt damit ich sie
einfach so schön darüber drosseln kann
und dann kann ich es auch besser
verstreichen und jetzt fangen wir an zu
schichten ich habe mir gerade noch ein
skateboard zugeschnitten einfach damit
ich dann später besser transportieren
kann weil eventuell bei wird am
eingeladen sind nämlich die mit und
mache dann den tests mit die lava und
ooohs und da schaue ich einfach mal
spontan das seht ihr dann ihr könnt euch
überraschen lassen die stadt jetzt mit
dem ersten boden ich glaube es nicht
direkt zum deckel für den boden damit
einfach hübscher aussieht und dann könnt
jetzt entweder so welchen blick ob ihr
könnt entweder so schichten oder ihr
nehmt euch jetzt zur hilfe nochmal einen
hohen tortenring da habt ihr halt den
vorteil dass es alles schön glatt und
gerade ist und es muss ja auch noch mal
zum kühlen in den kühlschrank und
dadurch dass es schon eine sehr hohe
torte wird so sieht einfach optisch
schöner aus kann man sich mit solchen
dingen helfen jetzt fange ich an da
erstmal pistazien creme darauf zu geben
auf den boden dann kommt ein bisschen
was von unserer seite mascarpone creme
früchte ihr könnt auch gerne nochmal
seine mascarpone creme obendrüber geben
und dann kommt immer jeweils die nächste
boden und ich sehe gerade ich brauche
das gar nicht verstreichen ich mache das
wirklich nur so mit dem löffel und
fangen dann schon direkt mit einer
dünnen schicht creme an und zum
verstreichen weil das jetzt schon sehr
tief ist könnt ihr euch entweder die
streich palette nehmen oder hat ihr die
xxl winkel palette zu hause habt dann
ist jetzt natürlich auch wunderbar
geeignet
[Musik]
ich habe die torte jetzt geschichte ich
habe den letzten hüllen boden übrigens
weggelassen und mit einer schönen seine
schicht noch mal abgeschlossen und das
ganze könnt ihr gerne noch mal für 30
bis 60 minuten kühlen jetzt kommt jetzt
immer ganz so fern wie warm ist es bei
euch in der küche die creme ist schon
recht fest dadurch das wird auch viel
mascarpone drin haben ich hab das jetzt
noch mal für 30 minuten in den
kühlschrank gegeben und jetzt könnt ihr
euch aussuchen auf welche tortenplatte
das gibt oder auf welchen taten teller
ich habe zum glück wieder skateboard und
runter da ist es ganz einfach das
anzuheben und hier drauf zu legen und
dann nehmt ihr euch nochmal den backform
löser dann nämlich jetzt das lange und
es ist jetzt das wichtigste denn wir
wollen uns ja nichts weg reißen sondern
wirklich mit der ganz feinen klinge hier
am rand reinfahren und dann eine runde
machen und dann entfernen wir den
tortenring ich lass das jetzt heute
übrigens komplett naked ich finde das
irgendwie
schöner beziehungsweise man sieht
dennoch seine erwarteten wie verhält es
auch viele schichten sind finde ich
irgendwie ansprechen und dann dekorieren
bin noch mit früchten und mit unseren
neuen ba klarer sorten das ist entweder
ist es jetzt ein spoiler oder sie sind
schon online es kommt ganz drauf an ihr
seht es dann in der infobox zwinz
verlinkt ist dann ist es auf jeden fall
schon online und da kommen wie gesagt
unsere baklava varianten lockung kommt
drauf an uns früchte und natürlich
unserem und sicher
[Musik]
also bei dem naked cache ist er so ein
seminar kitkat ihr könnt euch es ist
noch ein bisschen was von der creme
übrig könnt ihr das noch so ein bisschen
verstreichen damit richtig seminar fit
wird und
dann würde ich empfehlen weil die torte
ist recht hoch ist dass ihr euch nochmal
cake pops viele nehmen das kind die
vielleicht von anderen videos von mir
dann steckt ihr was einfach ganz so
random okay das muss man ein bisschen
kürzen einfach random reinstecken 34
stück aber kürzt das damit ist quasi
nicht oben drüber steht und dann seid
ihr auf der sicheren seite selbst wenn
ihr das transportiert das euch da nichts
verrutschen kann andernfalls würde also
kannst wirklich passieren dass ihr euch
so nach rechts kippt ich find's lustig
ist die ganze nämlich stehst aber ich
hoffe man wirklich mit oder
gespannt zugehört
aber okay toll gemacht dankeschön an
unsere cake pops des gekürzten der ksc
noch mit rein
[Musik]
so das ist die fertige torte ich glaube
wir nicht die mitbringen würde zu einem
familientreffen würden sich alle freuen
oder
wir können heute abend probieren das
würden wir dann einfach mit der block
kamera aufnehmen und anhänge nervig
finde ich schön was sagt er deshalb war
wirklich das was eure wünsche waren
fruchtig einfach zu kompliziert lag mit
bis das system also ich hab es sind
imame
sind schöne abschluss und unsere ganzen
baklava sind drauf granatapfel
dokumentation baklava das dorian vom
erst jetzt cool finde es ist jetzt auch
was ja auch komisch fand wieder mit
bitte nicht mit datteln oder so nicht
also ihr wolltet gar nicht so dass der
teig auch diese orientalischen zutaten
enthält aber kann ich manchmal auch
nicht also ich kann schon verstehen aber
ich kann's also nur du hast die ganze
die ganzheitliche ist erreicht was ist
noch haben müsse jeder selbst klassisch
auch wir sind jetzt im frühling einfach
so sommerlich frühlingshaft und parbat
wache fußballer genau wir brauchen
endlich zu reden
also leute krasses krass ist ramadan
projekts video gewesen ja noch dieses
jahr war echt kraft alle zwei tage und
ich finde auch jedes rezept für super
fußball hat so ist bald schon wieder und
ist schon wieder geil und genau dann
kann sarah an der stelle diese
fleischliche mitgemacht hat und erst
hüllen geschnitten hatte stellte konnte
also ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel
spaß zum nachbacken und schreibt gerne
feedback wie fandet ihr die ramadan
reihe und dann sehen wir uns im nächsten
elf teams
[Musik]
ich denke ich finde die idee richtig
cool wäre also ich dachte sowas habe ich
noch nie gehört vorher immer butler oder
so ist ja klar also eine torte zu ihnen
habe ich noch nie gehört haben
sicherheit zwei leute
also könnte man heute videoclips geht
das video läuft also wir sind jetzt
gerade bei unserem versuch die lager und
auch am start ich freue mich zu sehen
wie sich leben
also wir haben es heute zu zum
fastenbrechen gegessen und wollen jetzt
einfach die torte verpassen dürft auch
ehrlich sein also
atomico
war noch mal obst für den fach der
atomic so heißt denn bei uns
[Gelächter]
dass jeder sicherheit ein stück teilt
das ist mein gott also das grüne ist
distanzen creme
habe ich noch mit
untergehen
jetzt schon
sagen wo wir
können wirklich ehrlich sein ich habe
fast gemacht und auch ganz abgeschmeckt
und das ist gut so
leicht bei torten ich merke auch wie
günstig schmecken man bei vor allem dem
boden der z richtig gut mit excel word
problem
der boden ist ein super
weißt du was die lage kommen werden sie
direkt von der bank
diese woche war obendrauf dieses dollar
pro tag
das ist nochmal hier schauen der landtag
wie man sich das ist jetzt in extrem
bedauerlich ist schon extrem mit dem
markt normalerweise kleinen glocken ist
richtig dass rechtlich ist das richtige
dabei hatte es eigentlich zeit hier kein
mitgemacht ja klar das hat extrem es ist
so so weit zu behaupten
ich hatte angst wird in rom ich hatte
angst dass der zusammenhang hätte man
jetzt was stimmt nun ganz günstig mit
einem witz versteht aber auch der sinn
so richtig geht also los dabei beweist
dabei dort ist dabei beim pistaziengrün
dass noch mehr und früchte weil magath
mit und das nicht so schwer ist mainz
endlich nachbacken also genau so schön
weil wir jetzt viel mitgebracht hast
mach dir ein zu entlohnen auch das freut
mich ich finde den anstellt ist der
anschluss so der ist ja voll farbenfroh
in zeichnungen geil das ethisch mal und
hoch so weit so das sieht auch schön aus
so die ist einfach schön dies nicht so
in die breite und dafür dann niedrig ja
ich war ja dass der mittlerweile
antworten wenn die wirklich einfach in
die höhe und habe den ich habe ein stück
übrigens vom ich habe einen cake pops
stil bekommen und dadurch dass sie so
hoch ist muss sich die rente
aber das ist das kann doch wohl habe ich
auch noch welche
frucht tiger das volk also jetzt nächste
woche wahrscheinlich was dann kommt
ja
unbedingt nachmachen also wir sind jetzt
viele leute kommen mit überzeugt von
dieser tor
[Gelächter]
richtig lecker aber deine freunde werden
das ist meine freiheit auf jeden fall ja
also doch bis dahin gibt es
nicht dazu werden aber die ist weit das
ist ein kompliment oder comedy machen
ich hab dich
war in dem zusammenhang ihr könnt ja
auch mal den beiden folgen auf youtube
die machen den sich aktuell auch viele
blogs 77 generell ist auch regelmäßig
content nach
[Gelächter]
es wundert also ich wünsche euch auf
jeden fall viel spaß beim nachkochen und
schreibt den kommentare wie ihr wie es
findet wir den text handelt und dann
sehen wir uns dann erst mal zu du bist
alles so machen das ist mein abschied zu
[Gelächter]
[Musik]